Yemen is in the midst of a civil war but
it really depends from which perspective
you're looking at it to say what war is
being fought the outcome of the conflict
in Yemen has direct ramifications for
the future of the Middle East region
because of how it's played into the
sectarian dynamics in the region and the
actual power conflicts between Saudi
Arabia and Iran that is taken root
inside of Yemen there are now two
governments inside of Yemen both seen as
legitimate by their followers what we're
looking at is a situation where Saudi
Arabia is backing a southern government
that's based in Aden and recognized by
the international community and Iran has
backed the northern government in Sanaa
under the LDC Saleh regime it creates an
interesting dynamic where should the
country fracture into - there would be
an Iranian mini state on Saudis southern
border and a Saudi client in the South
of Yemen this is a significant
inflection from how Yemen used to be
where the entire country used to be
under Saudi Arabia's influence and the
growing presence of Iran in the region
is a concern how do you think the war in
Yemen affects middle-east dynamics let
us know in the comments section and let
us know what other topics you want AI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds